This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed, I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this.
He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the IHart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Keer Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
Hello, everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners. Wherever you are in the world, it is so great to have you here back for another episode as we, of course, break down the very important psychology of our 20s. I've got a question. Have you ever had that feeling of meeting someone amazing, feeling like this relationship, you know, it could really go somewhere or it's already going somewhere.
You're happy. You're fulfilled. Your friends and your family. They love this person. And then out of nowhere, this kind of small feeling starts to creep in. It's this feeling of, is this person really the one? Is this part of our relationship normal? Should I be having these doubts?
Is this a sign we shouldn't be? be together. It can definitely send you spiraling in confusion and facing all of these annoying questions leaves you doubting whether it is your anxiety or your intuition about this relationship. And this, my lovely listeners, is something that we call relationship anxiety or relationship OCD. And for those of us in our 20s, when, you know, we're kind of experiencing our first really long-term, important relationships, it can be a real pain and it can really ruin otherwise perfect and magical situations and magical experiences. And it can also leave us in a real negative thought spiral. So today, we are going to break down exactly why this occurs,
why we have been taught all these false notions of what a perfect relationship should look like. And when you should be doubting your doubts rather than accepting them at face value, we also have the privilege to be joined by an incredible relationship. coach Rebecca Orr, who specialises in helping people find relationships that feel confident and secure. She is perfect for this episode. Welcome, Rebecca. Oh, thank you so much for having me. I'm so excited. I'm so excited. And you are hearing a little UK accent, everyone. We had to arrange this from across the oceans. And oh my gosh, the UK to Australian time zone is a violent change. Like there is no time that works. I have some Australian
clients and it's crazy. She's used to it then. But I'm honestly, I'm used to it. You're used to it. When I like heard what you have to say about relationship OCD, I was like, everyone in their 20s needs to hear this advice. So before we get into that advice, can you quickly introduce yourself to the listeners of the psychology of your 20s? Yeah, of course. So as said, I am Rebecca and I'm a relationship coach that specialises in helping people with anxieties and insecurities in their relationship. So what I do is help people kind of take back control of their brains, create relationships that feel secure and confident. And really, it's a lot about their relationship with themselves, being able to trust themselves, being able to manage their own minds, kind of challenge
those fearful thoughts that their brain is constantly offering to them. And yeah, and really just feel back in control. And the reason I got into doing this was because I spent the majority of my teenage years and my 20s just feeling absolutely terrified in relationships, just so, so scared all of the time. And this is why the work I do is so, so important to me because basically I went through my my own kind of journey with this work with seeking out, you know, expert help and listening to podcast and going to therapy and reading all the books and all these things. And, and all these things. things. And yeah, I finally found kind of a set of tools, a set of concepts, a structure that really helped me to get out of this kind of spiral. And yeah, that made me realize that I need
to help other people do this. So it's work that I'm really, really passionate about. And when I say I can relate to everyone I coach, it's literally like coaching a past version of me in every session. You know, you are the kind of like the kind of guess that I love having on the show when it's someone who is not only an expert, but has lived experience with the things we're talking about. Not to like hate on anyone who's trying to help people, but I just find that you can only get so deep if you haven't been through it yourself. Yeah. You can only really understand the extreme anxiety that comes with relationship OCD if you've
experienced it yourself. We have to talk about this topic, though, because some people may not be familiar with relationships, OCD, can you give me a brief description of what it is and maybe what it feels like? Also, something I need to bring up. It has OCD in the name, of course. But I think people, if you're thinking about the typical kind of OCD that we might talk about, it is quite different to what I'm assuming most people are imagining. So I'm sure you will confirm, deny all of those thoughts or explain them further. But yes, give us the basics of relationship OCD. R-O-CD, relationship OCD, is where people have obsessive, compulsive thinking in their intimate
relationships. So it's going to feel like intrusive thoughts of doubt and anxiety surrounding relationships. And of course, doubt in any relationship is normal. Of course it is. But people with R-O-CD find that the level of doubt, the level of doubt and anxiety is uncontrollable. And it feels really intrusive and it feels really distressing. And what that can look like is constantly debating if the relationship is right. It looks like a lot of ruminating. It looks like a lot of monitoring and checking how they feel. So do I feel in love now? Like, oh no, I just felt bored. What does that mean? Am I attracted to them enough? It's a lot of kind of monitoring how they feel. There's a lot of comparing. So comparing your relationship to other people's
relationships, what you see on TV, on films, social media. There can be a lot of kind of trying to control your partner, trying to kind of nitpick. You know, if we don't want them to be imperfect. You want them to do everything just right so that we don't have to feel any negative emotion or doubt. If we can make them do it just right, then we don't have to feel negative emotion, which we will end up spiraling on and thinking that means something terrible. So it can, it can mean that people can be a little bit, not in a malicious way, but that they kind of want to try and control and micromanage their partner a little bit. There can be a lot of ruminating about missing out. You know, am I missing out on someone better, being afraid to commit to someone just in case
it doesn't work out? And even to go as far as people might avoid committing to relationships at all because they're so afraid to experience this doubt and anxiety. So yeah, it can be a really hard thing to experience. And for me, although I coach a lot of people with R.OCD, what I really experienced myself is more kind of, kind of, I feel like there's two kinds of fears. There's like the fear of being left and then there's the fear of like, I'm not in the right relationship and, you know, this relationship is going to end. I might leave them. For me, I was much more afraid people were going to leave me. But I think the, the fears are so closely linked and I coach so many people with these intrusive doubts in their relationship.
And yeah, those were kind of the most common things that we see time and time again. So I'm sure some of your listeners can totally relate to at least one or two of those things. Oh, yeah. And you know what? Especially in our 20s when we're like, I just want to have this great big love. And I'm so young and this is the time when I'm meant to be meeting people and dating and exploring if I'm going to sink my time. into this relationship, it better be the right person and I better be 100% sure. And I'm going to say this, like, I'm in such an amazing relationship. I'm not 100% sure. I'm like, think I'm 99.9% there.
But you are always going to have doubts and I actually think that's important because it causes you to continue to examine your relationship and to continue to consciously say, I do want to be here. You know what I mean? I think if you never thought about your relationship, all, it becomes this passive thing. But we want to find the balance, right? I'm also assuming, from what you've described, that a lot of people do find that they end up self-sabotaging relationships, that a relation, like their relationship patterns may be quite self-destructive, that they have a lot of regret around leaving past relationships, missing that person, being unable to move on. Do you find that some of your clients will come to you and say,
there was this relationship I had and in hindsight it was perfect and I can't get them back. What am I going to do now? Like is that something that happens? Yeah, I have coached people that have been in that situation where as we start to unpack their patterns, they realize, oh wait, it wasn't them, that it wasn't the relationship. It was the problem. It was my brain. And that can be a moment where people start to feel loads of regret and kind of almost
shame around that. but I think it kind of plays into a little bit of what the kind of underlying thinking error is, which there can almost be this scarcity around it. Like there's this one right person for me. And I know we're going to come on to talking about the one, the idea of the one as well, but we almost have this idea that there's this one person for me, and they're predetermined. They're like a needle in the haystack that I need to go find.
And therefore, if I've missed them, then I've missed them, but they've gone. And I think a big part of snapping out of this, ROCD kind of mentality is there isn't one right person. There are just billions of imperfect humans on the planet that you could create amazing relationships with. If it didn't happen with that person in the past because your brain wasn't ready for it, you weren't in the place to have that or they weren't or maybe now you are, but they aren't, maybe they're now dating someone else. That doesn't mean you've missed, but you're one great chance for love. It means that, okay, that person, it wasn't the right time with that person. And there are other amazing people
that you can create a great relationship with. So I think for me, it's always coaching them through that scarcity mindset of like, it's like that kind of, there's, there's one slice of pizza left in the box or like there's one partner left on the shelf, like, and I've missed out. No, there are always more amazing partners that we can connect with. The world is, the world is not short of people. And there are billions of amazing, imperfect, flawed humans that we, we get to love. So yeah, I think that's the way I would coach them around that is really looking that scarcity mentality. The scarcity mentality in dating right now, as I'm sure many of my 20-something single people can attest, is wild. Like, it's absolutely wild. It just, I saw this, like,
TikTok the other day and it's like, if you met your partner on Hinge, you got like the last chopper out of Narm, like out of Vietnam. Like, you got the last lifeboat off the Titanic. Like, it's terrible. That's hilarious. I know. And I was like, gosh, no wonder people feel like they need to like, no wonder people feel like they can't leave bad relationships, but also the sense of doubt around choosing the wrong person because if you've chosen the wrong person, eventually you'll be single again and it just seems also terrible and bleak, which it isn't. But I'm jumping the gun because I want to ask you this one question. I so want to get some of our basics down Pat. Are there certain people who are more prone to our
OCD relationship OCD than others. Yeah, so I think there's so many things that can impact these kinds of thought patterns. And one is childhood experiences. You know, if you grew up in a family where maybe you saw a lot of kind of problematic behavior in a romantic relationship, you know, your mom and dad maybe, or maybe they went for a really painful divorce and that was really hard to witness, you know, our brains are always absorbing beliefs. And we can absorb these beliefs from childhood that relationships are scary and dangerous or relationships aren't safe. Relationships will end. Relationships are scary.
And so childhood experiences is a huge one. Social conditioning, which I know we've said as well, like all these messages we receive about, you know, how relationships should look, the Disney movies we watched, you know, the rom-coms we've seen, all this kind of social conditioning can really impact the way we think about it. But I think some people do just have more anxious tendencies than others due to their genes, their DNA. And it can be hard to pinpoint. And I think my advice for the clients is to worry less about why is my brain like this and focus more on how can I show up with compassion and care to work with what I've got. You know, if my brain is absorbed this from somewhere, who knows where, could have been childhood, could have been a Disney movie I
watching I was five and my brain just really latched on to it. Like, who knows, let's just meet you where you are and learn to guide ourselves through it. Oh, do you know how refreshing that take is? I love to examine the why, but I think that it's like, it's the why and the now. And you need to be able to distinguish them because the past, your genetics, your personality, none of it is, like, none of it is, I don't want to say incorrectable. none of it is going to determine everything. It's right. It's set in stone. Yeah. We can end up trapped in the story where we're like, well, because my dad cheated on my
mum five times, like now I'm really bad at relationships. And that's not me mocking anyone that says those kinds of things. I totally understand it. I've been there myself. But we can end up trapped in that story where we identify as I'm a person that's bad at relationships or I'm a person that can't commit because of this thing. And when we tell our brains that, our brain's just like, okay, we don't commit.
That's who we are. And there's no way out of that. So, yeah, I think just being able to recognize what might have contributed with compassion. And then, okay, now what? What are we doing from here? This is something I talk about a lot. Also just in my personal life with my friends, what is the story that you're telling yourself that is making your life less amazing than it could be?
Because each of us is telling ourselves a story. Maybe it's not about relationship OCD. Just think about it in general. That we're telling ourselves a story around how we're incapable. We're telling ourselves a story around how we don't deserve certain things about what people think about us, about the fact that our relationships are always going to fail. Again, I'm going to bring in a pop culture reference here, which I don't do that often, but there is so much pop culture references to relationship OCD when you look for them.
It's the song, The Prophecy by Taylor Swift. Have you heard this song? yes i was like yeah i'm guessing she has and it's the sense of like i don't know if you've listened to the song if you haven't it's such a beautiful song and it's basically like her talking about how she's deemed to always have her relationships fail and anyone who is anxiously attached anyone who struggles with relationship anxiety anyone who has just been you know unfortunate enough to have had too many relationships end and end up being lessons will relate to that song of feeling like it's a prophecy, this is set in stone, and it most certainly is not. And we've talked about
the story that we might tell ourselves. What about the story that society tells us? What are we told relationships should look like? And why do you find that sometimes unhealthy? Wow, I could talk for hours about this, but I'll try and streamline it a little bit for the sake of not sending everyone to sleep. But yeah, we have absorbed so. many messages from society, from, you know, even, you know, the parents, the caregivers, teachers, everyone that we've come into contact with, our brains are always listening, especially as children, we're always absorbing messages. And, you know, we're kind of sold the idea of romantic relationships saving us, you know, especially as women. And then this is one thing
I want to say as well is that I think a lot of women in particular suffer with REOCD because they've kind of been taught that their romantic relationship is a reflection of their work and value. I mean, and if we think about historically, you know, at one point, a woman's romantic relationship was literally her lifeline. She didn't have a bank account. She didn't have a job. She didn't have a place to live on her own. She couldn't buy property. A romantic partner was, was her lifeline. So although we're not living in that, thankfully, anymore, you know, it still trickled down where women really believe that their romantic partner is a reflection of their worth and value. if they don't have a romantic partner, it's because they aren't worthy and valuable in some way.
And if they do, that person is like this mirror of whether they are worthy and valuable. And so, yeah, we put a lot of pressure on our romantic relationships. And we often kind of think of them as coming along to save us. You know, if we're single, we think, oh, I'm going to get this person come along and they are going to be this amazing person that's going to come along and complete me. They're going to be the other half of me. They're going to be my soulmate, my one and only. and then my life will be happily ever after. And if we think of the Disney films that we've watched, think of rom-coms.
You know, we always see them running off into the sunset together. We don't see the after part of the happily ever after. You know, we don't see the part where Cinderella's sat around feeling a bit bored and frustrated because the prince has been late home every night that week. Or, you know, we don't see them maybe start scrolling on their phones, not having much to say to each other or the fact that they've maybe not had sex for a few weeks because, you know, they've been really tired. We don't see the realities of relationships really played out to us, even on social media,
you know, and this is just, you know, it's not kind of social media's fault, it's just the way that it is, but we don't post our lows, we only post the highs, we post the engagement photos, we post those gushy Valentine's posts when we're all dressed up. Of course we're not going to post the mundane moments where we're just sat. I'm like, oh, look at me, like sat with my partner having nothing to say. We're not going to post that. and the brain then subconsciously believes that those things don't exist. The boring, the mundane, the negative just doesn't exist.
So then when we experience it, we think, what has gone wrong? There must be something wrong. Yeah, I must not be normal. If I feel like, look at everyone else is so happy, so connected, out doing cute things, having a great time all the time. And I'm sat here feeling bored and, you know, maybe we're not doing anything this weekend. Something must be wrong. And so yeah, one of the expectations we have is for our relationships to be happy and blissful all of the time.
And we think our partners are supposed to fulfill every single need that we have. And this is one of the things that I was saying about kind of people monitoring their emotions because they kind of believed that relationships. And I was actually coaching someone last night who said the same thing that, well, relationships are supposed to be happy, right? And we were like, I said, well, yeah, you know, happiness is one emotion. You're feeling your relationship. But what if you're supposed to also feel other emotions? And it was like a, it was kind of like a light bulb moment for her where she was like, oh, she thought that happy was the one emotion she was supposed to feel.
Sorry, I realize I'm talking a lot now. I get excited about this. Oh, I love it, please. But yeah, yeah, so we end up if we do feel a negative emotion like annoyed, irritated, frustrated with our partners, we start to panic and think, I shouldn't be feeling that. You know, why am I feeling this way? This isn't normal.
I think we're just so scared of doing it wrong that we become hypervigilant. You know, we start comparing. Are we having sex enough compared to other couples? Are we going on enough date nights compared to other couples? As if there is just this one set normal and we just want to know that that exists so that we can then rest assured that we are doing it right.
So yeah, there's a whole lot of expectations to challenge. And I think that is one of the biggest things that we have to do with our OCD is really looking at looking at what is my unchecked story of how relationships should be. What is the reality? And, you know, and a question I like to ask people is, if you knew that that was just totally normal, would it be a problem? And for most of them are like, oh, no, if I knew that it was normal to sometimes go a few weeks without having sex, like, I don't know, it wouldn't be a big deal to me at all.
Like, people almost need permission for it to be normal. like it's okay. I think it's because relationships are so nuanced and complex and complicated and they're scary. Like being in love is scary. We look to be validated by what other people are doing because that provides us with some sense of confidence that we're doing it right. It's like cheating off the test of someone next to you thinking that they know what they're
doing and they don't actually. And when you were talking about that client, that, you know, I have to feel happy in a relationship and you're saying, well, what if your relationship is meant to teach you other things? You know, as humans, there was a study I read recently that we have access to 34,000 different kinds of emotions, distinct different emotional states. How boring would it be if your relationship only fulfilled one?
That means you would have 33,900,000, 950s. 99 other emotions, maybe 998, if we also include love, that you would have to find elsewhere. Yeah. That doesn't sound particularly enjoyable. Yeah. I love that you said that as well because one of the concepts I teach is called the 50-50. And it's this idea that life is supposed to be about the 50-50, the 50-50 of positive and negative emotion.
And no matter where you are, no matter where you live, no matter what job you do, your brain is going to create the 50-50. And I always think of like, you know, when you think of people that are rich and famous and have it all, that my brain goes to like the Kardashians, you only have to watch an episode of the Kardashians to see that they are living the 50-50. They have a lot of positive emotion, but boy, do they have negative emotion too. And they have money, they have cars, they have, you know, glamour, they have the big house, their brain is still creating the 50-50. They're going to feel bored, they're going to feel frustrated, they're going to feel irritated, they're going to feel disconnected sometimes. And it's really this reminder that it doesn't matter where you are,
what you're doing. You know, on my honeymoon in December, me and my wife were sat on the beach one day and we were both just in a terrible mood. And we both looked at each other. We were like, this really proves the idea of the 50-50 because we're literally on our honeymoon on a beach. In love. And we're both really irritated. Yeah, in love. And we were both really irritated. And we were like waiting for the boat to pick us up. And we were like, we were just in like a bad mood. And it's just this idea of no matter which partner you have, no matter who you pick, your brain is going to create the negative 50, which includes boredom, frustration, anxiety, irritation, all the things you said.
Like, it's going to give you the whole spectrum. And I think when we can know that, we can worry less about, okay, which right partner is going to give me the exit ramp off that human experience? Which right partner is going to come along and save me from that negative 50? And just which human do I want to enjoy? loving while knowing my brain's going to create all of the emotions no matter what. Yeah. I love the way you put that.
I absolutely love it. We're going to take a short break here. Let us have a little break for water, a little tea break, a thinking break. But we will return very, very shortly. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%.
I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hard. and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person.
Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J.
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now.
Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and,
conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough.
Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross. Because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions. bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
Join me, Keer Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free Our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in. And her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case.
I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfectant. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesspian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. this is Love Trap.
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app,
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Okay, we are back with the wonderful, brilliant. Rebecca Orr to talk about relationship OCD. So, something I know people are thinking is, if my brain is going to create the 50-50 with anyone, when do I know what doubts to listen to and which ones to ignore? Because there are people who are just strictly not right for us. So do you have any tricks for telling the difference between an anxious thought and an actual doubt? Yeah. So there's a process that I would encourage people to try. And it basically
starts with self-soothing. Because in the moment where you feel triggered, as in anxious, you feel that kind of urgency, what we've got to remember is that your brain is seeing whatever the situation is as dangerous. Your brain thinks that this relationship ending is, is dangerous in some way. Or, you know, this partner not being right for you is dangerous. It's going to mean something bad. So it's sounding the alarm and you can think of it like maybe an overprotective guard dog or a faulty smoke alarm. I sometimes use that analogy. So your brain is sounding the alarm as if, you know, there's a lion about to attack you when really, okay, your partner just might not be a good match for you. You're not going to die. But so we've got to start with just kind of grounding ourselves because
when we're in that place of heightened anxiety or fear, the rational part of our brain, is not online. The prefrontal cortex, the part of our brain that is in charge of logical, rational thinking, completely offline, and it's the primitive brain doing all the talking. So in these moments, if you're feeling really triggered, you're having a lot of doubts. Just start by, first of all, observing the experience. So I like to do this by just shifting to the observer of my thought. So, okay, my brain is telling me this thought. Or, okay, I'm noticing my partner, you know, said this and my brain's making it mean this. Okay, I'm just noticing my brain is telling me this. So you notice it's kind of like you're shifting to observing the story.
Then we've got to sit and ground ourselves back in our body. We've got to calm the body down. Again, and we're signaling to the primitive brain. It's okay, brain, we're safe. There's no lion. There's no tiger. We're actually safe. So there's a whole process I teach on kind of grounding in the body. But it really involves being willing to sit and feel the emotions. Feel the sensations of that anxiety. Just notice where they are. Take a breath around them. Notice how you can just coexist with them. They can't hurt you. And try and just be present with that experience without trying to rush to escape it. And the client I was coaching last night, we were talking about this. And she always feels like it like it's an emergency. She has to solve it right away. So if her brain offers her these
doubts, she has to solve it. She has to know whether it's like, you know, right, wrong, go, what she's going to do? So we've been really working on, can she just sit and observe? Like, oh, okay, like I'm feeling this in my body. And this is the story my brain is telling me, okay, this isn't an emergency. This is just, you know, a thought and feeling I'm having. It's okay. When you do that, it's kind of like you're turning the volume down. So what felt like a nine out of ten on the anxious doubt, scary spiral scale is going to come down to like a four or a three or even lower. You can just bring your kind of, it's going to turn the volume down. it's going to bring the sensations down a little bit.
They might not go completely, but it's going to just make them just kind of more like background noise. Yeah. From there, that's when you can really check. Is there an unchecked story here? Is there an expectation at play that I need to look at? So I always like to get my clients to separate out what are the facts versus what is the story.
Just so they can check, is this something I want to keep thinking? So I had a client that would doubt whether her relationship was right whenever her and a harness sat in silence on the sofa scrolling on their phone. And so the fact was they were, they were sat in silence scrolling on their phones. And her thought, her story was, we should be more connected. We shouldn't ever feel bored. We should always have something to talk about. So we've got to challenge those expectations and stories. You know, is that really true that you should never feel bored ever just because you have a romantic partner? Like, why? You know, do you have to be in conversation all the time to love and care about someone? You know, is that really
true, is it possible you can have nothing particular to say in that moment and still really get on with that person and think that's great? So it's kind of like really challenging those misconceptions, those expectations. Is there a shut at play? And you know, who said, who said that you should be doing this? Where did that come from? Was that something from childhood? Was that something from, you know, social media or the kind of Disney films you watched or, you know, rom-coms? So doing that first is important. because you might discover after going through that process that there's no issue, actually. It was just your brain, your fearful brain, sounding the alarm to try and protect you,
and actually it's not a problem. Other times you might discover that there are things that are a deal breaker, that maybe, although you've challenged the story, you still don't really like this thing, or there's something that maybe that goes against a value of yours that doesn't feel good in the relationship. And that's going to be so much easier to see when you're coming from a calm, rational place, and you've challenged those stories first. I love that where it's like, okay, we need to get back to that regulated, calm state before making any rash decisions. I also think in my experience, and I've done a whole episode on this called anxiety versus
intuition, your intuition about something is not going to demand an answer from you right away. Your anxiety is urgent. Your anxiety wants an accelerated solution. so that it can return to an internal state of emotional homeostasis, your intuition will be like you make this decision in your own time. Yeah, it's a calm knowing rather than that anxious. Yeah, totally. Exactly.
And it all comes back to this. I also think there are some pretty obvious red flags, right? And I think that if you are continuously having this feeling of, oh, this just doesn't feel right. and it's making you miserable in other situations, like where it just won't go away and you are miserable because of it. And you've discussed it with that person. And it just isn't being resolved.
Like there is a genuine need that is not being met for you. It's like sitting on your phone with your partner. If you are sitting on the couch and you're sitting in silence and you're kind of like, I actually kind of enjoy this, but maybe we shouldn't be doing this, that's probably an anxious thought. But if you're sitting on the couch and you turn to your partner and say, hey, I actually really would want us to, I really want to connect right now.
And they're like, no, I don't want to. Leave me alone. And they're not listening to you. Yeah. Like that, I think that is an actual doubt. It's something that you can't collaborate through. It's something that like, if there's going to be this 50, 50, you want a team member. You want someone who actually can collaborate with and compromise with.
If that's not them, I think it's not going to work. What are some, yeah. Sorry. I'm sorry. I was just going to say, one of the things I teach as well is this idea of the want match. And it's this idea that we have different wants in a relationship. And some people will match those and some people won't.
So, you know, you might have a want for a partner that's really physically affectionate. And they might be someone that doesn't like physical affection. Well, that's not a want match then. And I think, yeah, when we can really, it's kind of like when we can calm the overprotective guard dog down. Like, it's okay, buddy. It's okay. We're going to be all right. we can then drop into that, well, what are the deal breaker to me? What is the kind of partner I want?
You know, no partner is going to be perfect. The person isn't going to do it perfectly all the time, but are we aligned with our values and our want matches? You know, do we want the same things out of a relationship? If this person wants to, you know, never really have sex, that's what they want, but you have a, you know, you have a really strong sex drive and sex is really important to you. Okay, that might not be a want match and that's okay too. So yeah, I love that you said that. And I think you're right, when we can kind of drop into that calmness, it becomes so much easier to decipher. And if you have respect for the other person, it's like, I just feel like that is also, it's just such a big thing. And if there's no respect, that is a deal breaker you should listen to.
I also believe, and you can correct me on this because you're the expert, but this is my personal opinion. I also believe that you don't have to address your doubts right now if you feel comfortable and stable. You know what I mean? Like the anxiety again is this urgent thing. I find that sometimes with my relationship at OCD I'm like, what if I feel differently in five years? And then I've wasted all this time and there was something five years ago that I didn't see and we're five years down the line and I ignored it and oh my God now my whole life is over. I think that is the story we've got a challenge as well. And sorry to cut in that. That is what I hear so much. When people say, I'm so worried that I'm going to regret this in five years time, I think it's so,
it's so interesting because if we think about, your brain is constantly telling you stories. And basically in those moments, we're saying, I'm afraid that in five years time, my brain might tell me the story that I've wasted time. And so I'm really afraid today that my brain is going to say something to me in five years time that I won't like. But we forget that in five years time, we get to decide whether we believe that. And I think, this is why one of the things I was think of RCD is we've got to really look at what our brain is so afraid of underneath this all. Like, okay, if you are in this relationship and it ends in five years time, what is scary about that? And I think, you know, there's that thought you said,
well, it means I've wasted time. That's not actually a fact. That is totally an optional way to think. And, you know, I always think I got married last year and I hope we're going to stay together forever. but if in five years time, we don't. We break up for whatever reason. I'm never going to think, oh, I wasted time. That was the wrong relationship. And now I need to beat myself up for that. I'm going to think, no, that was the total right decision for me in that moment.
And that was a beautiful relationship. And if it ends in five years time, I get to go and create another great relationship. And I think that is really what we need to look at. You know, what is it that you're afraid of? Is it that you're going to tell yourself you chose wrong? if this relationship ends? Is it that you don't believe you could handle the breakup? Is it a fear of getting divorced?
Is it, you know, that you think that you then won't be able to meet anyone else at a certain age? Because I think we almost need to be willing for our relationships to end and know that we can handle them. But for so many of us, we see the idea of a relationship ending is failure. So we think, okay, in order for me to see this as a success and believe I'm good at relationships and I'm doing it right, this relationship has to last. forever. So we almost then start to work backwards and we're like, okay, well, how do I know that this person's going to be my forever person? Well, then I need to make sure that we never argue. And then we start to look for all these red flags and it just, it ruins our experience of it. Versus what if it didn't need to last forever necessarily? And again, I'm married. It's not me saying
that I don't want my marriage to last forever. I'd love if it did. But I'm open to the possibility that if it ended, I could be okay. And I wouldn't beat myself up. I wouldn't make it mean I failed. It wouldn't be a failed relationship. It would be a relationship that lasted, however long it lasted. So I don't know what you think of that and what that brings up for you, but that for me is a really kind of important piece of this as well. I'll tell you what I think about that. Absolutely amazing advice. I think that's incredible advice. And I think that that is going to change the brain chemistry of a lot of people listening because it is absolutely true. It's like just because a relationship doesn't last forever, doesn't mean it wasn't beautiful, doesn't mean it wasn't right then.
And I think it's so funny, you've just unlocked this in me of like maybe I think that all that our doubts are, all that our anxiety is, is our brain trying to have some insurance against future suffering. Yes, that's it. It's just like, okay, well, if I worry about this, this is like my insurance. This is like, you know, stop this. I'm sorry, but your anxiety is going to do nothing to stop you from suffering in the future. it's just going to make you suffer now. And again, there's this huge study in psychology that basically says, we tend to over-dramatize or intensify how we think we'll feel in the future.
So you're sitting here right now and you're saying, well, if I don't get the dream job now in 10 years, I'm going to feel so terrible. Actually, they've done studies on this and they've found most of the time people actually feel pretty neutral. we over-exaggerate how we think we'll feel in the future. And this is the same thing with relationship OCD. Your relationship doesn't work out. It is going to be devastating. But it's not going to, your life isn't going to be over.
You will be fine. People, so many people have made this pilgrimage, have had relationships that have failed. And they have thought it was absolutely perfect. So your anxiety doesn't mean one thing or the other. It's just, again, this insurance. But I want to ask us, this follow-up question, which is you're sitting here, you're doubting your relationship,
you're with this amazing person, how do you deal with the guilt of that? Do you, the guilt of like, well, if I'm having doubts, maybe they are better off without me. Yeah. Oh, that's so, so common as well. And, yeah, there's so much shame and guilt around this. And yeah, I think the most important thing to remember is that you aren't your thoughts. So the thoughts you have of doubt of judgment towards your partner, of doubting if you love them enough, of doubting whether they're right for you. You're not those thoughts. You're just the observer of those thoughts. Those thoughts are just random sentences that your brain offers you. And your brain works through repetition. So the fact that they come up so often is just because those are the ones you've
been practicing for so, so long. They're like your brains, it's like a radio station that loves to play the same three songs. Like your brain is going to keep. offering you the same thoughts that it loves to play the most. And that's all these thoughts are. They're just, they've been programmed into your brain from so many places, maybe past experiences, maybe messages from society, maybe, you know, early traumas that you had or just these fears and doubts about what it would mean if the relationship ended. You know, that is what created these thoughts. So it's kind of remembering that you just get to observe the thoughts. You don't need to beat yourself up for the thoughts being there. And, you know, having those doubts isn't a sign that
you're a mean, unloving person or even that you don't love your partner, it's just a sign that your brain has been trained to think in a certain way about relationships right now. So I would always say if you notice you're feeling guilt, if you're shaming yourself, try and shift to some self-compassion of like, I'm just a human with a very normal human brain and that's okay. You know, my fears and doubt aren't me. I'm just the observer of them. That's okay. There's a new therapeutic practice called radical self-compassion that I came across a few years ago just like change my life it's like you can on you can promise to unconditionally love someone else why can't you promise to unconditionally love yourself yeah yeah that's completely possible
like it's also coming back to this you know that's a term oCD is in this is in relationhip oCD is defined in large part by intrusive thoughts that we feel like we don't have control over Yeah. That really aligns with this guilt, this sense of like, why am I thinking this? I must be a bad person. And people with just, you know, regular OCD will find that a lot. Like, why am I thinking about, why am I thinking about crashing this car? Why am I suddenly thinking these terrible things?
This means something about me. And what you're saying is, you know, it doesn't, which I think is really, really beautiful. Yeah, it totally doesn't. It's just the way your brain has been trained to think right now. And that's okay. You can just be, it's almost like you can think. think of your brain as the separate entity from you. Like you can use different analogies, whether you want to think of it like a scared,
frightened animal, like a little toddler, you know, like you're the parent of it, like whatever analogy works for you. But you want to remember that you are the manager of your mind. You're not your mind. And really changing your relationship to it is so important. If every time your brain says something to you, you freak out and take it super seriously, or you beat yourself up for having it or you start to scream at it and why are you like this?
You know, that's not going to be a very great way of managing it versus. is calmly being able to observe what it's saying and guide it to where you want it to go. Again, such beautiful advice. We're going to take one more short break. And when we return, we've got some wonderful listener questions. So stay with us. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available.
I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more
fulfilled healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking.
What the hell does George Bush got to do a little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick you here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s.
To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for Black.
people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we
are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch life becomes about wins and losses Steve Burns, Dustin Ross because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth
or are you a good person because you're afraid because that's two different intentions bro absolutely and that's two different levels of trust I want you to just really be a good person Join me, Keir Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story.
This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfectant. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marincolini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona.
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Okay, Rebecca, this is something I've been doing recently where, you know, there are just so many niche questions that people have. for me out there about specific topics and I want to make sure that we cover everything that they ask. So I've got four listener questions for you today. Actually three listener questions and one bonus question for me. So I'm going to tell you those right now. Starting with this first question, which is coming from Emma, I feel like I'm totally madly in love with my partner and we have a beautiful relationship except for one thing. I feel like we cannot communicate and we're always having fights slash tension over the same things over and over again.
Should I break up with them or do I just accept this as a flaw that they will always have and live with it? Yeah, that's an interesting question. And I think it was kind of hard for me to give an answer in the sense of knowing more about the context of the situation would be really important. But also, there is no right answer. You know, there's no expert out there that can tell you what relationship is right for you or when to stay or when to go.
That's never my job. But I think before you make a decision to leave or staying, it's just to do some real self-reflection on your own thoughts and feelings and the way you're showing up. Because if you do decide to leave, this can just be a really great kind of opportunity for you to take back control of who you are in relationships. So, you know, noticing, okay, what is the pattern in this communication?
Is it that I say something, that they say something, and then, you know, I get defensive, then they get defensive. Like, we want to just look at what is going on and really come back to owning your side of it. You know, okay, well, what, how are you approaching conversations? What is the feelings you're having and what are the reoccurring thoughts driving that? You know, do you keep making him sighing, enduring an argument, mean he is unbothered or like, whatever? And can we just, let's just challenge some of that so we can see, is there a different way to
navigate these moments that might turn the volume down on them completely, that might make it less of a problem. So again, that's really hard to just coach on in and just a short, pithy answer on a podcast. But I would do some work on that, really looking at, okay, what are my thoughts and feelings during these situations? And how do those thoughts and feelings have me showing up? And is that intentional? Am I really showing up as my intentional, highest self in these moment. And if not, no, there's no shame there. We all, we all struggle with that from time to time, but spend a moment just trying to work on that for yourself. And I always advise getting curious about what might be going on in our partner's brain too. You know, if your partner keeps
having the same response to something, let's get curious. You know, what might that be about for them? You know, do they keep hearing something you're saying and interpreting it as, um, they're not good enough? You know, me and my wife had this at the start of our relationship. Whenever I kind of kind of gave some feedback or some criticism on something, she'd get very defensive. And when I kind of dropped into that curiosity and I even got curious with her about, you know, what is it that comes up for you when I say that? What's going on for you? It was that she thought I was saying she was a bad part. And I wasn't saying that at all, but that was what her brain was hearing. So I think we can bring that curiosity and and then see what comes out with that. But yeah,
there's going to be at some point where you've really worked on yourself in it. You know you're doing your best. You're showing up with your best self. And the other person isn't able to meet you where you want them to be or that they're not able to to kind of have the same values with you in terms of communication and and openness or, you know, emotional regulation, whatever it is. And I think, yeah, sometimes it's accepting that, okay, this is the person for who they are. This is who they are. Is this someone I want to commit to loving for the good, the bad, the ugly? I love that advice. Our second question comes from a listener called Sean. Sean asks, is there a correlation between relationship OCD
and an anxious attachment style? I mean, yeah, I would definitely say so. I think with anyone with an anxious attachment style, their brain is kind of programmed to see relationships is dangerous, unsafe. They think that how this person behaves will either create safety or, you know, danger. So they are constantly monitoring, you know, what's this person doing? What does it mean about me if they leave me? What does it mean about me if they, you know, don't, they're not as interested anymore? And, and there's this kind of focus on the other person to create this inner feeling of safety and security. Totally, of course, then relates to our OCD because it's kind of the same fixation. The brain is seeing that thing outside of you, that person, that relationship, as either safe
or dangerous and trying to work out which it is and kind of create safety from it. So yeah, I definitely think there's a there's a correlation there and for me i i think whether it's r oCD whether it's anxious attachment it's really coming back to looking at your internal experience rather than trying to focus on the external rather than focusing on what is my partner doing or not doing it's okay what are the thoughts and feelings i'm having and what is that bringing up like what is whatever's going on out here bringing up within me um because that's where the safety and security is actually created. It's never created by the thing outside of us. It's created by our own thoughts and the beliefs we have. So yeah, I hope that answers that
question. There's definitely a correlation. And yeah, coming back to whichever it is, getting curious about your internal experience is really important. Yeah, excellent advice. So this is the final listener question. My relationship OCD is so bad that I cannot go more than a day without thinking that I should break up with my partner. I love them, but some part of me really just wants a break from my own thoughts. Would you recommend taking some time away just to get my relationship OCD under order or should I stick it out and work with them? It's a really good question.
And again, I want to say that there's no right or wrong. if you feel like you just really need a break, do it. You know, you know what's right for you. Let yourself be the guide of that. But one thing I will say is that often when we're experiencing an emotion we don't like, like anxiety, we think the solution is to remove the external thing that we're blaming for causing it. So with RECD, we think anxious attachment, it's the partner. We think, let's remove them and then I won't have to have these thoughts and feelings.
And there's some truth in that, you know, if that's the thing that triggers the thoughts and feelings, okay, you're probably going to get some relief. But what we don't really realize is that, well, those thoughts and feelings are still going to be there the minute we go back to the relationship or the minute we start another relationship. You know, I've seen so many people leave relationships thinking, okay, this partner was the problem, I'm going to leave. And then they have the same anxious, doubtful thoughts in the next one.
And they're like, oh, damn it, like, turns out changing the partner didn't really work. So my advice, if you feel like you're able, if you don't feel like, you know, you're at a real burntout place with it, that you just. need the break, take that if you need it. But I would also consider what if instead of trying to escape the thoughts, what if I could work on changing my relationship to them? So if your brain keeps offering you the thought, this relationship is wrong for me, I should end this relationship, you want to start changing your relationship to that thought. So when it comes up, it can be like, oh, there's my brain's favorite story again. I'm noticing my brain is offering me that story again
that this relationship is wrong for me. Interesting. like here's my brain's favorite story to tell me right now and kind of change how seriously you're taking it. Consider how does it make sense that your brain is offering this to you? Oh, it makes total sense my brain wants to keep going back here because it's terrified of this relationship being wrong for me or it's terrified of me ever having to go through a breakup in five years time. Okay, so it makes sense that my brain keeps wants, keeps wanting to offer me these thoughts. So there's so much more work you can do and that there's different. kind of tools you can use for diffusing thoughts. There's things like you can kind of sing the
intrusive thought to yourself. It kind of lightens the mood of it. There's things like kind of seeing the thought coming from this like separate voice from you. There's different things you can do, but that would be my advice to you is how can you make the occurrence of this thought less of a problem? Because what that's going to do is turn down the volume on it altogether. It's going to seem like less of a problem. And from there, your anxiety is going to come down a lot as well. This final question is for me. And I ask every single guest on the show this question, what is one piece of advice you'd have for anyone in their 20s that has nothing to do with what we talked about today? Well, the thing I was going to say was change our relationship to our
thoughts. But I guess I can't say that. We've got nothing to do it. Honestly, yeah, I know. It's a bit of it. Honestly, yeah, I know. It's difficult. And yeah, honestly, then the, the piece of advice I'd give to anyone in their 20s, it's just to go easy on themselves. I know that sounds like such a basic thing to say, but I think sometimes it does kind of tie into what we're talking about, but we have so much pressure from things we see on social media, from expectations, maybe our parents have of us,
from what our, you know, friends are doing. And I think just remembering that, you know, life is supposed to be fun, that, you know, you can actually change so much of your experience of what you're going through in any situation by just lightening up and being a little bit more of a friend to yourself about it, you know, offering yourself that compassion, being your own biggest cheerleader, and remembering that, you know, that there's nothing that could happen that you couldn't be equipped to handle. And that is something I really focus on a lot with my own clients is looking at whatever that fear is that worst case scenario and considering, you know, how could I feel
empowered to show up to handle that if it happened? You know, what would I want to think and feel if that happened? So yeah, I think kind of a mixed bag of advice there, of course, as I was going to say, your relationship to your thoughts and changing that is so, so important, but also working on having more of that lighthearted, compassionate, you know, kind of supportive relationship with yourself is such a game changer. And if you can master that in your 20s, your 30s, your 40s, it's going to all be great. If you can work on that relationship with you where you know, I'm going to have my own back no matter what happens. You know, it's going to be great. That's such a resounding, beautiful way to finish this episode. I want to thank you so much for coming on.
I'm going to leave all of your links below, but where can people find you? Yeah, amazing. So I'm on Instagram mainly. So you can find me at Rebecca or coaching. So that's Rebecca and then O-R-E coaching. You can also come find me on my podcast, which is Master Your Relationship, Mind Drama. And yeah, I'll send you all the links to the website and things like that. But yeah, it's Instagram on my podcast mainly where people can come find me
if they want to know more about thought work and managing their thoughts and managing their anxiety. I talk a lot about that on the podcast as well. I know your podcast is actually the perfect. If this is an episode that you really related to, go and check out Rebecca's podcast because there is so much advice there. But as always, if you enjoyed this episode as well, share it with a friend who might need to hear it. Leave a five-star review wherever you are listening.
Make sure you're following along. And make sure you're following along on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. It's where I got the listener questions today. It's where I love to engage with you all. If you've made it this far into the episode, hello, lucky, lucky, lucky. I want you to leave a little magic crystal ball emoji in the comments because that's what we think our relationship OCD is and it's not. So it's also a great way to know. Be the loyal listeners.
Yeah, who's listened this far? And as always, we will be back next week. Until then, stay safe. Please be kind. In the theme of today's episode, be gentle with yourself. And we will talk very, very soon. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs.
when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side
a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist.
They take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that, trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
On the Look Back at a podcast. For 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors.
Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? Listening to learn the hard way with your favorite therapist and hosts Kear Games.
This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the IHard Radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. This is an I-Heart podcast Guaranteed Human There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.